bonsoir c'est presque un spécial
eurodisney que nous vous proposons pour
cette édition car il y a un an
exactement jour pour jour le parc
d'attractions ouvrait ses portes
un anniversaire qui cette année coïncide
avec le lundi de pâques autant dire
qu'il y avait affluence cet après midi à
main de la vallée pour la parade
happy girls est en anglais dans le texte
grandiose comme il se doit est déclinée
par tous les personnages de disney de
mickey jusqu'au petit dernier le
marsupilami plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes étaient là parmi
lesquels quelques vedettes pognon smaïn
henri salvador
nagui ou l'acteur christian clavier